[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEVA RECHAV: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Geva and today I
will be talking about App Maker.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
App Maker is a new
G Suite product
for building web applications
to improve your work.
In today's webinar,
I'll introduce
App Maker and its
key features, show
some apps our customers
have built with App Maker
and are using to
run their business,
and show you how to
build apps with App
Maker in your own company.
We'll have time for a
live Q&A at the end.
Our work often involves
multistage processes--
several user roles
throughout the process--
for example, Help Desk Ticket
Filer versus a reviewer
and respondent.
Some work flows
typically require
data from more than
one source beyond just
a single spreadsheet, as well
as capabilities distributed
across two or three different
G Suite or other products.
Customized UIs and flows make
our work faster and less error
prone.
To create those, we can build
web apps with App Maker.
App Maker lets
employees in companies,
whether they are business
or financial analysts,
IT developers, and
just anyone who's
enthusiastic about
improving their team's work,
build web applications that
are specifically addressing
their company's unique needs.
Whatever vertical your
business operates in,
whether it's retail,
finance, communications,
entertainment, App Maker
lets you build applications
by connecting to the data
you need to process--
wherever it resides and
however it's collected--
design UIs that are useful
and beautiful for users
to understand their
workflows, and creating
event triggers and internal
logic to take the actions
needed to streamline business
processes efficiently.
Many companies
run their business
using well-known apps
from leading vendors,
for CRM, HR, marketing,
as well as productivity
and collaboration.
These apps have been deployed
as SaaS in many companies,
small and large, and are
used by millions worldwide.
However, every company
has a unique set
of practices based on their
vertical, customer base,
and competitive advantage
built over their time they're
in business.
These include automation
off processes done manually
or using sub-ideal
software combinations,
such as email and
tables, that have to be
tracked separately and aligned.
Many of these applications
have direct impact
on the business outcome.
As we will see later
in the webinar,
the steps to build an app
with App Maker in your company
is relatively short and easy.
When compared to full
software development,
the flow is much shorter.
It does not require extensive
engineering software skills
and has several
data model creation
tools and visual widgets with
which you can design the look
and feel of your app.
There are also many actions
that can be triggered
on events, such as data entry.
App Maker is launched as a
G Suite Additional Service
last month.
While we are still working to
ensure that App Maker meets
the high standards required
of G Suite core service,
we launched it as an
additional service
so more customers can take
advantage of the product
right now.
App Maker is now available
to all G Suite Business
and Enterprise customers.
It's also available to G
Suite for Education customers.
We announced two significant
features at the launch.
One, Google Cloud SQL is
now supported as the default
database, automatically
created for all App Maker apps,
but you can still bring your,
own database and connect
it using JDBC or a REST API.
Two, G Suite admins
now have oversight
on the activity and usage
of all App Maker apps
in their company.
At Google, we are
committed to providing
our best available services
and principles with App Maker.
That's why we are
compliant with ISO,
and we are also up
to the standards
of Google Cloud with regards
to security and privacy.
Our product supports
accessibility so users
with different abilities,
inabilities can use it easily.
And from G Suite admin
console, G Suite administrators
now have visibility
over the apps running
in their organization,
including owners, usage metrics,
and OAuth permissions.
Expanded OAuth
whitelisting controls
mean that
administrators will also
be able to prevent apps from
running without their approval.
And distribution of
apps inside a domain
will be able to be run using
the G Suite marketplace.
Now I'd like to move over to
the second part of our talk
where we will take a
look at what customers
are building with App Maker.
Our customers
typically build apps
to support their
line of business
across verticals such as retail,
mobile operators, and gaming
entertainment.
We also see applications that
help energy industry vendors
control their plant process
eligibility across the world,
and also supervise what's
going on in those plants.
We have mobile operators
who are building
their whole go-to-market
program with App Maker.
And retailers are using App
Maker to create price quotation
systems that take
into considerations
discounts, volumes, and
special requirements
from their customers.
Apps to streamline
operations and work flows
are also popular
in many companies.
We see customers
building applications
to do budget tracking,
project management
inside their companies, build
dashboards for security,
and also use it
for app migration.
One example to
illustrate this is an app
built by one of our
customers, Electronic Arts,
to streamline a
critical business
process they had struggled
optimizing previously.
Before using App
Maker, several Sheets
were used to track various
human resource types required
to create many of their games.
These human resources include
game designers or studio
managers.
And by checking project
calendars in parallel,
humans were allocating
their required resource
to a scheduled project.
It was tedious and
quite difficult
for EA to optimize
resource allocation,
to get the right person
on the right project
at the right time.
After building the
app with App Maker,
the matching between
a project need
and available human resources
is done by an algorithm
automatically, reducing
allocation errors
and achieving higher
resource efficiency.
In the future, EA is
thinking about iterating
based on allocation optimization
learnings from using this app
and introducing it to
future versions of the app.
Another example comes from
ATB, a financial institution
customer from Alberta, Canada.
At ATB, there is a large
number of processes
that involve a customer-facing
team member sending information
requests to the operations
team for additional processing
at the back end,
the back office.
A leftover from their Microsoft
days, many of these requests
involve filling
a Word Excel form
that gets emailed to a
shared inbox for processing.
This was time-consuming
and made it
difficult for both the
requester and processor
to track their work.
Some of these request
types have now
moved to a Google Form Solution.
But for once it could
benefit from having
workflow controls and
functionality such as request
status and assignments, or
ones that need extra validation
or calculation, ATB
turned to App Maker
and built apps like
the one we see here.
For foreign cash
purchase sale request,
the app gives every
bank teller an easy way
to request foreign cash
on behalf of customers
and provides a way to
track all their requests.
Additionally, the app
reads exchange rates
from the ATB website to populate
the suggestion box for currency
with the accurate
exchange rate every day.
ATB is using several other
App Maker apps for their loan
management process,
the bankers' loan
limit check up,
a centralized way
to review and process loan
applicants' questionnaire
and match the right
product for them,
while another app
schedules appointments
with the right bank
representative at the closest
branch.
As you can see, the
apps our customers built
are branded with
their logo and styles
so they can look an integral
part of the corporate business.
Fun fact, App Maker started
out as an internal product
at Google.
And today, we have
hundreds of App Maker
apps running internally.
Most Googlers are
not aware they are
using an app built by App Maker,
as it looks and feels just
like any other corporate app.
Globe Telecom is an
international telecom provider
from the Philippines that
has 65 million customers.
They have built several
internal operations apps
that streamline their workflow
and actually change their paper
trail processes to be
automated completely.
One of these applications
is a travel approval app
that allows every employee
that needs to travel somewhere
to request their
travel itinerary
and get it approved through
the chain of approval
within less than two days,
whereas previously it took over
a week and involved
a lot of paper,
emailing inside the company.
Another app that they've
built is the Memo app,
which is patterned from the Memo
Routing template in App Maker
and used by all their employees
to standardize the memo
content, and also contribute
to paperless environment
in their company.
They have thousands of employees
using App Maker apps currently,
and they are looking to expand
and build even more apps using
the product.
Now let's take a look at how
we build an app with App Maker.
I'll show how we do this
in five easy stages.
The first one is to
define your data model
and connect to data sources.
This means that we have to
define what data our app
is going to be working with.
And the most popular
way to do this
is to import a table
from a spreadsheet, which
can be done easily.
And that creates a table
in the SQL database
that is created
automatically for every app
that we start building.
If you don't have a
sheet with a table ready,
you can define your
data model manually
by defining the
fields, one by one.
The second stage is to design
the UI of the web application.
Here, anyone can choose from a
palette of widgets what the web
pages will look like, for
both data entry using forms
and to present data to the users
of the application in tables
and other widgets, like maps.
You can also change
the styling here
by formatting the
spaces on the page
and what the overall
layout will look.
And you can also adjust it to
be good for mobile devices.
You can also apply
your brand identity,
as we saw for our customers,
with HTML and CSS code that
will run on the browser.
The next phase is to bind
the data to the UI elements
and trigger in-app events.
This is the stage where
you actually outline
the flow of the application.
You decide what
happens once somebody
enters data, for
example, and also
invoke automatic actions,
like sending an email,
or just stitching the
flow of the internal logic
of the workflow that
you're automating.
Once this stage is done, we move
over to defining the user role.
As I mentioned earlier, users
of the app can be different
and can have different
permissions to do
different actions in the app.
Some people enter
data into the app,
some people view reports, some
other people take actions.
So we can define all these
roles inside the app.
And once this phase
is done, we can
preview our app to see what
it will look like in reality.
And once it looks fine to us, we
can publish it into the domain
and then other users
can start using it.
To start building App
Maker apps in your company,
please check out
Google's Developer site
on the App Maker section.
Now, please stay
tuned to the live
Q&A. We will be back
in less than a minute.
I'll now take a few
questions from the audience.
First one is when will App
Maker be FedRAMP certified?
FedRAMP is a certification for
US government institutions.
And we are right now in the
process of possibly getting
this next year.
The process of getting
FedRAMP certification
is usually pipelined
into an agency
that does that for
different software products.
And App Maker is in the queue to
be certified sometime in 2019.
Next question, can I publish
apps outside of my domain?
Right now, this is not possible.
The reason is that we follow
strict security policies
with Google Cloud and G Suite.
The way that we are
going to approach this
is to extend the
reach of App Maker
both to users and domains
in several stages.
And one of the first ones
would be to share applications
across domain.
The way to do that
right now is, let's
say, between two
different companies,
you can package your
application in the first domain
and send it over to the
second domain offline,
and then deploy that
application in that domain.
One of the other areas that
we are looking to expand
is to allow users outside
of the G Suite domain
to use the App Maker
apps, but we still
don't have an ETA
for this feature.
So stay tuned in the
following quarters
to hear when we do that.
Next question, can you
build mobile applications
with App Maker?
So, the answer is yes.
And we have various
customers that have already
deployed mobile applications.
The way they did it is that they
designed the web pages to fit
mobile screens and tested them.
And they are already
using them in production.
We do not have ways to support
complete responsive design
in App Maker right now.
But what we are going to do
in the following quarters
is to provide
interim stages where
you can have
different viewports,
and also design the
breakpoints in your screens
so that applications look
better on mobile devices.
In the future, we'll also
have mobile-specific widgets.
But these will probably
come sometime in 2019.
Next question,
besides Cloud SQL,
can you connect to
other databases?
As I mentioned during
the presentation,
we support any database
that can be accessed
through JDBC or a REST API.
That covers a lot of
databases in the market.
And you can connect to
those databases by coding,
as part of the app, a service
that will access that API.
So you can add access
to any database
that you have, either already
working in your company
or that you want to deploy
with an App Maker app.
It will involve coding, though.
So if you don't want to have any
coding involved with accessing
a database, we recommend
using the default
Cloud SQL that can
accommodate any data imported
from various sources.
Is it possible to build
workflow apps with App Maker?
Yes.
I think we try to like
demo here an application
built by Globe Telecom,
for example, that
showed how a travel
approval process, which
is a workflow starting from an
employee asking for a travel
itinerary to be
approved, mentioning
the reasons for the travel,
the business need for that.
That goes on to a
second person that
calculates the cost of the
travel suggested, and also sees
whether it's in
cap or out of cap
or requires specific approval
from the financial point
of view.
Once this is approved,
a manager has
to approve this,
and finally, someone
from the operations that does
all the travel, like bookings.
So all this process has been
built in a single App Maker
app.
There are different
types of users there.
There are people that file their
approval requests and people
that review it and approve it.
And that's an
example of a workflow
that you can build
with App Maker.
There are many more.
And you can also check
out some of our templates
inside the product to see
other workflows that can
be supported by the product.
To summarize, I'd like to remind
that App Maker is a new G Suite
product that allows to build web
applications with easy access
to G Suite APIs and
a built-in Cloud SQL
database, over
which you can build
line-of-business
applications and workflow
operations in your
company pretty easily.
And to check those out and
try them themselves, please
refer to our Developers site
under App Makers section.
Thank you so much for watching.
Please tune in next Tuesday
for the next Cloud OnAir.
[MUSIC PLAYING]